[Music]
the idea of ​​getting them to talk about
uncertainty and how we can understand what
are the things that our models don't
know about and be able to measure them and a little bit of
a way of trying to bridge the
gaps between what is the
theoretical version of some things from  machine
learning together with the practice of what
we do from day to day to make it
really work I
work in sap as a
natural language researcher
and against a little perhaps a little cost
of some things that we do well because
this matters a lot to us
during the talk we are going to start by
defining  that the uncertainty in
theoretical terms beyond the
ambition that we can have later we are going
to make a title for the theoretical part
to talk about this concept of the
Valencian neural networks
finally to apply it to really the
problem in real life talks about the
revolution  stochastic and basically see
how you can use some of the
small applications that there are but there are
several others that  We are not going to touch
these lights bases, the same later, in the
end, how is the return in case they
realize it, well, what do you want
then, uncertainty
in that, for example, we work
automating customer service conversations
and we have a lot of problems
that fall into the realm of language  one
of which is to classify
classify intentions that come
voice text messages
then suddenly there is a message that
asks for an account to check a balance
ask about technical problems perhaps
to unsubscribe from a service etc.
then I am interested in knowing  If
I have a model that tries to classify these
things, I am interested in being able to know which things
are the ones that really move or does not
understand that it is not the same or that it
is not sure that it is not the same as the
things that the model is sure
are talking about any  another thing if
I can understand that I can realize
when to pass the conversation to
a human agent for example and avoid
v  Whether or not we understand chats and
I also got to the online but
also offline I can use this
information to realize what data to
tag and be able to make
better models more efficient as quickly as
possible without having to make so many
annotations let's go deeper  a little
about his relationship with the girl
so
I want to about this problem of
classifying intentions I can try
several more basic solutions I can
stop things like nice valleys bag of
words even kings whatever is approved
in all those things before pressure to the
point that he has  enough arts
have action the bi werning solution
I'm going to tell I think that the entire
audience knows more or less what they have
but in 30 seconds two seconds
that it is composed we have pairs of points
in this case it would be one-dimensional
we want to take x there then we have to
putting together a function that leads to those
excesses and avoiding and not doing
and composing by putting together some blocks
the first is  For example, the
linear formation and matrices w that he multiplied,
I can also use some
non-linear activations such as immobile prisoners,
nothing more. Basically, these are the
blocks that build planning models.
Not for the most part, in most
cases, once I have that model
armed, it would be a  type of function that
have some loose parameters can be
adjusted using the passion for this framework
that cost me how much how much does it look like the
x that those doubles give me but
when it looks like y it takes
real prominence and I can minimize it
then that  it's great achievement we use it
works
and functions real problems and that's the
big reason why we're talking about
it if there's a lot of problems
about everything you have to buy
cepción and pattern machine within lepe
on television and other domains as well
that  they make it so useful
you also like this because it has
several levels of abstraction that is to say
even before we mentioned these blocks of
linear layers non-linear activation
all these things can be combined
not only to build the model but
also to optimize it we can insert
an optimizer there are several families that are
simpler more complex we can insert
regularization it
is like a mountain in these ingredients
mentality can increase and scion  that you
can't combine and abstract in the
sense that I don't have you're thinking about
the detail of how anything works once
I'm going to use and that's also one
reason it's successful in my opinion
another big reason why it scales great
candidates in these algorithms over
all thanks to
stochastic saying minivan they say they are
linear that is to say it goes through the data a
couple of times and they reach unlike
the algorithms before sbm that suddenly
are quadratic so it makes it
effective for the universe of
billions of data and therefore  last there are
great software tools that
help us put this into practice whether
it's now training self d  differentiation
walking and putting into production is
maturing more and more well that
contributes a lot to the success that
deep mind solutions are having lately
but to be fair
those problems also test it works but
when it doesn't work I have no idea why
because we have no fundamentals or  great
theoretical foundations to a greater extent
to understand what is
the reason why make presence
by gradient in a
billion dimensional space find a
global minimum kept increasing the
questions that don't make as much sense if you
don't think about it
also works like the black box if
these levels of this action these
blocks that we compose it is not that we
interpret as not here I am
taking it out
when the nouns that it finds the
verbs and this is combined if not really it
is as if it puts all that in the mix
and there is a solution but we cannot
interpret it most of the
time
if it scales as a great candidate but I also
need it and  They will be candidates because if I
don't have too many it's very difficult for the
good ones to work for you
and lastly in general they are easy to
change and this is because our
models don't know how to say I don't know
what happens to a lot of people too
we're going to do a little to  this and
talk about why we tell ourselves and what solutions
are coming out to be able to attack this
labeled problem so before
I start I want to motivate you because it is
important to know what we were saying, the reality is
that the more we begin to use
this type of movement not only to predict
or stop  Suddenly show a start
we will make an advertisement but we are not
to make important decisions in
real life they leave the online and we begin
to apply it to autonomous vehicles to
medicines
the cds
laws etc we are going to use these new ones to
make decisions and in that decision is
where it turns  It is important to be able to
realize these uncertainties. For
example, this is an image of an
eyeball that has a disease called
diabetic retinopathy that leaves many
people blind every year is quite
difficult to diagnose 6 relatively few experts
who can do it
so there are many giant companies and
also startups trying to put together
models that can detect this
disease well if
a camera is going to diagnose you  to ensure it
would be good to understand at what
point
this diagnosis has to be escalated to a human to
realize why he is not really sure
that it is an eye a person who is
totally outside the tel ungrateful etc.
another example if he mentioned
autonomous vehicles in the image of  an
infrared camera that is detecting
relating these objects are there the car
the trucks well suddenly
a person crosses in front of it and the skater it
is also important that I can tell
when to pass control to a human it
is not obvious
that we need to be able to do a  little this
introspection at what
moment is the networks putting something that is
outside of their domain training expenses
also adversarial examples that are
coming out quite a lot airbus there is a lot of
research on that topic this is one from
this year
that is the camera of a tesla
and what is on the right that is
shown in the panel of
in  the cabin of the car is detecting
the lanes are not there well these
investigators what they did is put
some white dots on the street
you can see there we continue to see
in the resolution of the screen but there are
about three white dots that happened
there and that the impact that  it has that is
that the lane detector suddenly
thinks that it is the empty lane and with it it
did not have the impact that the car goes
in the wrong direction
this was found by people from this
security law who reported and where it
had to start they fixed it later no  is
another example of the adversary point of view
that is really trying to
confuse it but this one is necessary
that naturally arises its examples
when  you take a model out of its
training domain
well then
I think there is enough motivation so
let's talk about the
Valencian annuals which is a tool that
helps us solve it
[Music]
you may think I also
thought a lot that when I have a
problem with a model  doing
classification and returns a
probability for example
binary classification tells me 09 100% 0% that
the model is showing uncertainty the
reality is that only in part that
is the model serial number that
seems like a probability it
is not necessarily exactly if the
model  you are sure this is sure example
imagine that this is a model that
is reading data from a sensor the x axis
for example it is a pacemaker it wants to
detect it in case something like that is about to have a
heart attack
then I have my model with the
data that  they are there between -2 and 2 more or
less then the output is applied
there is an earthquake life the output and then
it's a number that I'm a person who
lends you with the probability, so
suppose that almost all the data that well
3 0 and 2 from that sensor
were data on how well I teach, so
the model there is going to affiliate to a classroom,
one suddenly among  -2 and 0 never
had a heart attack and in cases between -2 and
minus 3
to 70 times and then something
like this goes somewhere now suddenly someone comes and the
sensor breaks for some reason it starts
normal and measures 4 and a half so why
do we maintain  to our model to
generalize for
tells us to extrapolate interpolate ba
really the lines are going to sexually to
what are the surroundings of the
training domain and most likely it is
going to give the probability of 100% infarction
in that datum that is really
totally outside the  margin
is not what one would expect maybe if
this really gives me the uncertainty
that as I get out of the training domain it
really starts to
converge to 0.5 next which is I have no
idea what this is  going on
for jordi
the impact is another 80 maybe it should
converge to those games like this but well
then we have to be careful not to
interpret those numbers as incentives
that we are going to see exactly why or
what they are experiencing the reality
is that there are two  types of uncertainty
one they call random and the other
epistemic you have perhaps more
key concepts the talk is a bit difficult to
understand sometimes so think with my
mouth in a mediatorial sense imagine
not in the following context the
critical variable observing I want to predict
it can really take several  values ​​for
example if I want to predict the weight of
a person according to their age
if it is impossible to predict
exactly because really for a
graph there are a lot of possible weights
and what is a distribution then if
I have more data if I continue counting
data and me thinking more people maybe that
curve of what I can predict of the weight
of an 18-year-old person is going to be a
a little less staggered a little
smoother but really it's not going to
stop being a curve I'm not going to be
sure
how to attack it has to be achieved is
arts there would be for example adding more
files or the person's ID is to
give a  absurd example or also
suddenly that for me measurement perhaps that
distribution is not really because there are
many values ​​but because I am
living badly
from the degree we have the
epistemic uncertainty where perhaps if the only
value but I do not have enough data it did not
see information well enough to be able to
To determine it, for example, if I have a
model to classify different
species of dogs and suddenly they come out
with a dog of a species that never
lived and I saw only one example, memory
will not be sure
and I would need more data, more photos of that
species to be able to recognize it.
another example this very interesting paper
by kendall de 27 was trying
precisely to measure and distinguish those two
uncertainties
the pr  problem is called
semantic segmentation classification there is a photo that
is half dark there which is
a camera photo of a car and what you have to
do is expected is to distinguish
which part of the image is what things are
in the trees the car from  the street and the
variety etcetera then the model
did a fairly decent job
in this country but they show how to also
obtain epistemic random uncertainty
and they look at the
random uncertainty is quite concentrated at the
bottom of the photo although close to the
horizon which is where really
surely the  entire models
with the data commented on the model and
the annotations were not consistent it was
difficult to distinguish because
what is in the background is not well seen so if I
get more data more photos of the same
instruction where they follow a pattern of the same
scheme as the background  it is not
well understood I am going to improve it that uncertainty
is really an actor and a change from the
other side that epistemic type
this case appears it has to do with this
training model and the model does not understand
what is seen under the car that
they look at it and quite similar to the error
that it made would enter wait the man
had and they differ
then to be able to solve this
problem for example  what that paper
does is use the few Valencians in the
spotlights they did what it tells us is the
parameters of the model and twice the
weights are no longer a number 5 that he estimated
but are also several rapporteurships yes
then I start with a belief a
system  For Georges, about random variables,
what values ​​does w have a chance of
taking? For example, a reasonable
lot would be that it is quite small, that the
prices are enormous, and then, once
I observe the data one by one,
I am going to alter my
priori distribution and it forms  what he calls the
posterior distribution in this case, for
example, the middle blue list, which
is also the beach, is wide because without being accurate,
instead, as  I am having more
data, I am more confident because the
more finite the distribution, the more
starts I have,
so I am updating and I am having
a better estimation of the
parameter buttons so that you know you like the
subject of graphic models that are
the same written in the graphic mode context
what does that mean up there
is my weight and I sample it from one of an
a priori distribution which is how much I
think the weights could guarantee imagine
maybe a normal then our w or
just once that is not that I already have it
for each x along with  that weight w I can
calculate y but calculation of y is not
deterministic as in a typical
neural network so at the same time x always comes out
1 and but there is also a
probability distribution imagine
if the problem is a
regression problem so I want pressure number
that  distribution in general is a
fixed variance abnormal around that
number
and if it is a classification problem you
want to offer a  a class in general is
a happy one for binary a multi class
then yes well sorry one more thing if
the upper part is a double of what
I am showing it has to do is not
related anymore to this
epistemic uncertainty the uncertainty of the weights
instead the  bottom part one that
I already have a fixed weight that is the
random uncertainty
so I complicate the valleys is
a fairly simple intuitive account that
what it tells me is how much the
subsequent w is worth once I keep all the
data what are the possible values  of
the weights
I have a slide with beads I am going to
try two accounts to motivate her as
much as possible so
please excuse me but the young women that
if I have my distribution a posteriori
wv I already understand observe all the weights
train my model I can calculate that the
comments at the end  of the day I can
calculate how much
y is worth for a new x so I am x
little stars so what you have to
do is quite intuitive is to average
all  the possible doubles according to
my distribution a posteriori that
can be intractable if what I am going to
do is really add over all or
ingenuity what is done is a type
of Montecarlo estimation to show a
pair of doubles according to my
distribution  it is posterior and the
averages ready and with its position and wrong
and calculate the probability for a
little x star new out
of training measures now the problem that
appears written with that posterior is
quite difficult especially because of the
denominator of the valley rule that  it's
a
partition function you have to add over
everything over all the x's and only if it
gets chaotic then what you usually
do is you approximate the
later instruction it's called
approximate differentiation but it's just now a
set for our new ones you have to
see if you knew at  month I would have put one
here it appears from tita which is my parameter
to parameterize the possible doubles if
this parametric or for approx  Imaging my
instruction a posteriori so I
do that in training in this
context is to choose tita so that it
really minimizes when those two things are similar,
that is, how much
the posterior distribution will appear and really to
the right and to the left the one that I am
choosing
and the distance action that I use so
that you know it is called the key
curve divergence but it is not that
important in the context either and if one
develops that account
two terms appear and although they look
difficult they are quite
intuitive the term of the  left is
the speech therapist and remember that there are two
more common scenarios 1 of that
regression and reclassification 100
regression I told him that p is an abnormal
to the real one a prediction then the pda
normal what ends up being
the squared difference of the real emi and
the and that I predict exactly the mean
square real that we use to
understand a regression model and if it
were classification what appears  ce is the
cross entropy so the same is the
most common loss function that we use
to understand a network but obviously it
seems to add up mostly the doubles with
me with my illusion is to get
approximate and then another term appears on the
right which is when
it seems my approach against pressure
if we choose a reasonable cloth in general
something like the normal one is used it ends up
being a common
and current conversational term for example l 2
of my weights then there is something super
similar between a normal net with the
difference that there is  a sum over
double time there I am adding over several
possible weights it is like I have many
models at the same time a kind of assembly
so my question is someone is
sara sometime between new vallejiana neural network
let's
go to the hands
and he asked her there in this room  it is not
another in general
well almost all of them the good news is that
if they wore clothes they
were wearing some form of
radiation because
what europe is is  the concept of to
do to regularize or to use to
make a little more robust training
of my network I grab some neurons and
convert them to zero randomly a
probability that sometimes to do 0.1 0.2
is pressed in the middle layer is put in
the initial layer  now the little arrows this
would be a two-layer dense network the little
arrows represent the weights of my
network I continued to double a short 2 for example
then thanks to clarity converting
those neurons to 0 exactly the same
as converting the rows of my
matrices to 0 if then
we can rewrite a little bit what
does drop out that to the same result
but the counts a little different
where we are now from obviously
converting to 0 some rows of the
mother 3 matrices
and that is exactly the same as what I
wrote before making inferences
bayesian so clarity
loss function where in this case my
parameters tita is the matrix are the
weights w
and the probabilities of  the different
other w's
are according to deleting some rows from the
matrix so the probability that w
is equal to tita but with two rows
deleted is I don't know 0.1 times 0.1 times 09 they
appear what is the evaluation of the
drop
then  As I said before, they are delivered
with drop out, really
Christian disinfection ordination
, what is the use
of this, that although having is the same as predicting,
it is not exactly the same as predicting
when we put on a layer of clothing that is
basically made smaller in all of them because it
is a little bit it would
be  multiplies by 1 - p let's say
europe to compensate in expected value
the effect of converting some rows to 0
and that really, although it
makes a bit of sense when it comes to
maintaining what is expected, it is not so intuitive
because it is the same to shrink everything create
a row of chicama then what it
proposes and what makes theoretical sense
if we think trapped as an application
of this is really can say in the
way that I did not say before if
prome  giving over all possible weights
what does that mean in this context and
this can be done with three lines of
code in this case it would be python but
then almost the same
if I have my model that has the pau
inside and I want to use it to
make new predictions  With this
technique, first line model train, what
it does is not train anything, but it
notifies all the stochastic layers of the
model that, for example, drop out that they
really apply in general in python,
at the beginning we get to the point of
val and it makes it pass  this move it like this
where it is not stochastic it does not
explain europe but it reduces the
weights well if it gives 2.30 it does that
it will really apply the drop to the
next line what I do there is
copy an input 10 times 20 times to be
able to do the  predictions
of the same input a certain number
of times that it will give to the different ones
precisely because the process is not
terministic
and well now we are going to each of you
could decide  I confirm that I am very
inefficient because I have to go
10 to 20 times slower when it comes to making
predictions. In reality,
the extra cost is marginal precisely
because this, in general, my model operates
in bumps, especially if you think that is not
an acceleration.  of hardware it is the same to
predict one that I saw that almost the same
because the cost is not funny well there is
once a result that is going to
have the output 10 times that is going to be
different what I can do is average
them
and then I  What I am going to have, for
example, if not, a higher classification is an
output that is averaged for each
class and it is going to be one I would expect much
better than actually using the other way,
which is to reduce all the weights a bit and
not only can I calculate the value  expected
the average of the output but you
can also create the standard version then
each
the output there of each class the score
of each class suddenly I have a range
I have an integer of confidence and that
agreement  it's the confidence bar,
well, they're back, we can use them too,
so we can really measure and
realize,
for example, I could look without a
smaller interval at the lower point
of the classes, it is more likely that it will start to
tread with the other classes, it is a good
intuition that  my wife is not
too sure about this if it
means that in some
model evaluations it was not perhaps more
likely another comment and another lesson
that these ideas give us
for europe is that they recur for a
long time people did not use
drop out in  recurrent networks tripoli 7
m because it really didn't work well or I
didn't think it was because throughout the
tooth it becomes a composition of
many functions because it has to
agree with the sequence and well the
operations used it and what
these ideas basically tell us is  that the error was that when
applying the group for example in all
the connections that go from one
recurring module to the next  eventually
all the layers became 0 and
this information was lost, that is, if
in the first application in Europe it will
become the first in the second
the third in the third the second
throughout all that employment
eventually turn off some neurons
no useful information arrived at the
end and the planes did not flow well
so what this idea tells us is to
have to apply
you have to delete the same column in
all the steps
and that then is a consequence of
all the information going to be deleted
help them  to flow and with that it really
worked for it is already past I spoke
of a language model called w of the
stm
that of a research paper that
she chews out of merit that used this
idea of ​​tropea to the same in the same
places in all the  positions of the
recurring network and with that you really
get much, much better results
then to apply recurring what I
said before evaluate
[Music]
average  I will change the outputs of the model if it is the
same as in another context in Europe or
later
I will touch on the positions if this is
what happens in rn that did not happen before
because we did not have this concept of
resources and well another idea that this gives us
is yes  we look at it at the level of the
first layer is that if we are going to delete
words it is a type of
data augmentation that is usually done we
have to delete all the times that
the same word appears in the
sequence are not all ideas that
this theory gives us that really  They worked
very well to achieve these results
in the language.
Well, I wanted to show you one more example
before moving on to the applications of
how it manifests itself in certainty and how
I can measure it specifically, how to
get a number that has to do with
the photos of that one that we saw  before
semantic segmentation imagine three
examples
if I am going to evaluate my
binary explanation model 10 times to see if I
really have confidence in the
result then if  my model
every time says 100% yes and until the
end well there really isn't much this
man isn't sure
what happens instead if what he tells me is
50% the second time 50% it won't be 50% and
so on all
and  then the model is sure that
it has no idea in this case
and the third example is the first time it gives me
100% that if the second time 0% 100% 0%
then there my model is
completely crazy yes that is, it has no
idea what pressure  do then
notice that what happens is that in each
little example in each sampling in of those 10
10 the entropy is 0 next it is done
once is the only thing 100% with zero
percent always zero but it does average
all the outputs of the model that is
what I suggested before suddenly I have
50 percent left and that has
entropy 1 so the
average difference is between topical application the
average in which it allows us to measure that
is where the uncertainty appears this
mica track that is what it tells us  this
model does not know but could  know more if
the and give you more information
well it is implicit in the snipe of code
on how to measure that was not enlightening
simply calculate the entropy from the
average entropy so
to close we are going to talk about some
applications
I am going to see two the first one is learning
There
was a little talk about reinforcement yesterday and the talk of
the dan about this brought was to explore
exploiting and the beauty of respect to the no,
for example we have people who
start to stop welfare the s want to
reach
gd govern and avoid the traps so
a  framework that allows you to do this is
this epsilon grid and that the brave that
is with certain probability takes a
random action epsilon and if not try to
do what I want to be the best
possible good but that approach is very
inefficient yes because when  when it's my
turn to eps and where to explore
I'm going to try absolutely any
option with mana probability that with the
same problem that's bad because to
begin with I saw it  da real we can't
afford to do that we can't with a
double probability to the right and see
what happens it's total
later we can learn but apart
because it's efficient because suddenly
there are some actions about which
we already have information that it is an action
bad if then what we should
do is explore the things about
which we are not sure if something I
know is good it is not necessary to do it
let's say something that we are exploitative
if I know it is bad for sure
why am I going to do it and about  All if I'm going to
die, what he wants is to try to use and
go do things that have much
more science than man, one way to
do it, for example, is if some work
on multi-arm things
has to do with Thomson sampling, it's
sampling from  that confidence interval
that the model output gives me,
then I am going to do the action that is
shown with the most probability and that
way if something is very accurate it will
guarantee me that it is going to  exit if something is
very low with great certainty it will never come
out more created and I will never do it
and the other the other application has to
do with the ctc the demonstrative sampling
and there is the mention at the beginning or what
interests us a lot in it  sap if we want to
be very efficient with like this
we want data imagine that I want to
make a model that classifies the
blue recognized points
what can be done is as a
lie erre account that I have some
annotations just see how I
should annotate more things to converge
to one  good classification region as
fast as possible and there it is showing an
example of how it is done in general when
the means are simple, for example
linear reaction, something is done,
things are looked for that are close to the margin
of decision that is very difficult to do
or it does not work  also when we have a
very complex model where the most
realizations are a line but they are
a somewhat chaotic thing
then we p  It can help
again to be able to measure the uncertainty in
the different examples that have not yet been
labeled to go and label themselves
and improve the number in this way there are
different ways to do it, this is usually
used, which is called the acquisition function, it
is like a score that tells me
what is the next point that of food to
label
there are several uses some measure the
entropy others measure the margin the
probability of the highest pp that
the model gives you versus the second the most common
is a small rate of variation is what is the
difference between 1 and p  largest of
the classes that I am distinguishing the
last oval bolt is the one that is based on
these methods that I told you before
of average entropy for its loss of
herds if I am
calculating stochastically that is 10 20 samples
of the classification I can do  this
method and in general
here are some results from a
legal paper from 2017 and the line that
was above is showing completely
random s  and look there is the y-axis that is
the error
and the x-axis and the amount to all that
I want to download as fast as possible
so if I go I want to do what
we are going to do naturally to
label data the average as
it goes  wyk to be able to do
it is much worse than to be able to use
these techniques it is true that val is not
the one that works best everything works very
well but in all these cases throughout
this graph it is being used to evaluate
the method of averaging the
different areas  of the model because
because it gives me much better and
more precise outputs when it comes
to a regime with little data if
we can little data it is very common for
the model to say 100% when it really
has no life then when averaging this and
any of those methods on
operation
and  that's more or less all to summarize
and what will show you to stay is that the
output of a neural network doesn't
necessarily measure certainty or not
100%
the next thing is that at
regularize stochastically be drop to other
similar methods we are really
finishing our models and if
we know if we can measure the
uncertainty we will be able to pay better
and nadal is one more experience these are
the slides there is the link apart from the
qr
modals to library  very useful to make
our asset that has all these
questions of x that one can try if they
already have to be tagged,
this trick can be done by
deleting the tags and seeing that
they would remove the acquisition discussion and
lastly if they stayed we would see
these with curiosity  topics of his for he
commented on haring's thesis to the
several works that I showed the 23
where they are from his thesis were very well
explained he is great at creating doctoral
theses they are good better than a
paper published in euros because they usually
have an intro and a lot of
information  more cup to be able to
get out with the subject so launch super
eating
status
questions
hello es cape  z that I stayed in the middle
now
at one point you said that the
neural network does not know how to say I do not know that is
classification with the option of rejection
how is this approach improved
and getting the network to say that it does not know
I only needed to have the first
part  of the question
at the time of the talk you told
that the neural network is difficult for you to say I
don't know if it is this that when it really doesn't
know how to go from 0 to 1 that is, it says there is one
in certainty that we then that in
mathematical classification one  calls
classification with reject option
would have to add the
reject option to the classifier which is not
easy to change the paradigm so that it
accepts a reject option so
what I was wondering is to talk about working with
these uncertainties how to improve access
to the reject option  or generate the
perfect rejection,
that is, in principle, what this method does to us
is a way of measuring this
uncertainty by averaging in
quotes a bunch of models that
some weights that are off are almost the same,
so what we can
do is measure, for example, the
average entropy by their own entropy, it is
the oval method, we can see the
confidence interval of the projections, that is,
how similar they are, and once you
have  that is a bit of the
business rule of thinking about how I am going to
decide when I am going to execute my
prediction what I would recommend doing
is, for example, one can do a
rich precision type analysis what
is done alone goes very well with the
application and what is at risk in
a certain use case then one
could say well if I remove all the
cases where
my model is accurate how these metrics affect me
and then evaluate I mean I can
remove the ones that have entropy more than x
then I lose a little  the state of
needed to expand a little bit every corner
and so on and make that decision but there
is not a cousin what it has meant of
all that you could think of it
is a problem  in each of the
different classifiers, changing the
paradigm to add the
rejection option is complicated because you have to
make a force that you are going to decide, that's why
I was asking you if you had already planned
that it be donated and to be able to use it and
well in the case  of binary in which
you have two options and record precision
it works well, perhaps there it is to put
a decision in which this cut is going
to stop well classified and the rest we are
going to add in the rejection option
some certainty that it is calculating would be
the probability with which I followed the
rejection
yes I have seen examples and in my experience
of trying once to try
to create an extra class that would be not
off topic
in my experience that may vary it does not
work also to be able to emulate it that
way because it is  creating those classes are
very heterogeneous, very multimodal,
so they don't end,
you can't approximate it well,
but if I understand that there is a need
to be able to insert as actively as possible,
I would also ask with the question it
is a prick and if you can talk a
little more about the question of
random and epistemic uncertainty
I understand the basic idea I think that what I would
understand that you say is this that you
can in a dog is a Labrador with
probability 0-  1
if you look at it closely enough and
with the measurement you need to measure it but even
if the Labrador the weight the muscle mass
anything that dog the
random variable with random uncertainty
basically sometimes I imagine that there is like a
border as he tells me to the dog then
an epistemic has a contain a
moment where to go from one to the other,
let's say there is not, that is, a little bit
to have to take the point here that
it is understood that they are discriminated as
completely different things but there is an
assumption and it
is not only 100% 1  hundreds of others have obviously
installed certainties coexisting I don't
know what other example of this gene as
best as possible there are even people
who distinguish  gue the universe of the
random part extends what is
measurement error of the other that is
really inherent to the problem because they are very
different and in general what I also
specifically in more and Domínguez who
cannot play with another dimension that is to
add features  It remains that the
problem is better in the sense that in
the
classical universe we usually talk about
uncertainty, it is reducible because it is on
top of it, there is a noise in the process,
as if it tells you what the subatomic consists of,
there is
the theory of the world, but it really
is not  reducible in that sense by
reducing from rhode my
error when testing and I can add more
features but it is quite difficult to
take it to zero I
need a little
how about very good the talk I had a
question about the latter that you
also just commented that it is  there are some
cases where your expenses are not normally distributed
or have a very high
kurtosis such and that noise that you just
commented on is very difficult  to get out of the
financial dishes we work
with financial data and emblem that
you have is that you cannot limit the
uncertainty I do not know if you know or
worked once for the joy of trying
to limit the uncertainty in cases
where it is much more difficult because the
data is more instructed with a wall or if
you don't work with financial data so
they don't let you be the expert to
answer on that subject if I know there is
but like Friday's talk about
test probability and some tools
are very good to do a little
The modeling part is richer, that
random uncertainty, that is,
normally, as we do in the middle of
regression, we go and plug in a normal one
with fixed variance and that is obviously
super limited, so this manufacturer
allows the brake to
optimize parameters, yield, etc.,
put it in, I also do not know how to predict the value
of the  variance or model it as a
citizen process or other kinds of things that
allow you to model that noise for  It's
much richer and also parameterize
even from that
time when you have a phenomenon that is
mostly temporary
and there are temporary dependencies. I think
it can work much better
, that is, what it ends up doing is
actually getting rid of
this limitation.  of the regression that is
a word or something like
that that the variance always has is
constant at the time of regression
and